stell dir vor du könntest in die
vergangenheit reisen in welche zeit
würdest du reisen um den größten
positiven einfluss auf die
menschheitsgeschichte zu haben
würdest du versuchen einen weltkrieg zu
verhindern würdest du den menschen im
mittelalter von der dampfmaschine und
arzneimitteln erzählen oder würdest du
an den anfang der menschheitsgeschichte
reisen um eine bessere gesellschaftsform
aufzubauen
die möglichkeiten sind endlos aber viele
von euch hätten auch angst davor in die
vergangenheit zu reisen
jede noch so kleine änderungen kann den
verlauf der geschichte entscheidend
beeinflussen und unbeabsichtigte folgen
haben filme wie zurück in die zukunft
und butterfly effect zeigen uns dass
selbst kurze gespräche den ausgang eines
kompletten lebens beeinflussen können
und schließlich ist genau das die
aussage der chaostheorie
jeder noch so kleine unterschied zum
ausgangszustand beeinflusst das
endergebnis auf unvorhersehbare weise
aber wenn wir angst davor haben die
gegenwart zu verändern ist es nicht
paradox dass wir nicht das gefühl haben
heute die zukunft beeinflussen zu können
was macht das schon aus was ich denke
studieren oder arbeiten
der verlauf der geschichte im großen und
ganzen interessiert sich doch nicht für
einen einzelnen menschen wie mich oder
wenn man genau hinschaut dann haben die
großen entdeckungen und erfindungen
eines gemeinsamen die neugier des
menschen im späten neunzehnten
jahrhundert gab es einen neugierigen
physiker der mit kathoden strahlrohren
experimentierte und durch zufall etwas
spannendes entdeckte als er die rühren
mit schwarzer pappe abdeckte leuchtete
eine flüssigkeit auf seinem schreibtisch
weiter obwohl die pappe eigentlich
jegliches licht abblocken solcher der
name dieses tüftlers wilhelm röntgen
er experimentierte weiter mit diesen
mysteriösen strahlen und machte sogar
ein bild von der hand seiner frau das
allererste röntgenbild seine erfindung
hat die medizin grundlegend verändert
und uns viele wichtige erkenntnisse über
den menschlichen körper gebracht
und alles was es dafür brauchte war ein
zufall und neugieriges nachforschen zu
einer ganz ähnlichen zeit forschen
botaniker namens friedrich reinitzer an
karotten um genauer zu sein er wollte
herausfinden wie cholesterin aufgebaut
ist und extrahierte dieses ausleben
gemüse dabei fiel ihm auf dass die
flüssigkeit ihre optischen eigenschaften
verändern kann
obwohl ihr aggregatzustand derselbe
bleibt ein unterschied von nur 30 grad
macht die vorher trübe substanz
plötzlich klar
neugierig geworden untersuchte der
forscher weiter holte sich hilfe von
anderen wissenschaftlern und fand
schließlich heraus dass flüssigkristalle
für diese sonderbaren eigenschaften
verantwortlich sind
80 jahre hat es dann gedauert bis diese
entdeckung die welt veränderte aber
heute kennt jeder liquid crystal
displays und die chancen stehen nicht
schlecht dass du dieses video mit hilfe
von flüssigkristallen siehst aber auch
heute ist noch lange nicht alles
erfunden
taylor wilson war schon immer ein
neugieriger junge der im garten seiner
eltern experimentierte
doch schnell wurden seine experimente
abenteuerlicher er war gerade einmal 14
jahre alt als er 2008 der jüngste
konstrukteur eines kernfusionsreaktors
wurde in der garage seiner eltern begann
hülsten das projekt und testete den
reaktor später erfolgreich im keller
einer universität die seine neugier und
intelligenz unterstützen wollte gerade
einmal zwei jahre später entwickelte der
nun 16 jährige taylor ein neues konzept
für einen strahlungs detector dieser
arbeitet mit normalem wasser anstelle
von teurem helium 3 und kann somit hohe
kosten einsparen
taylor wilson hat ein patent auf seine
erfindung angemeldet und plant diese in
zukunft überall dort einzusetzen wo
nukleares material geschmuggelt werden
könnte
vielleicht denkt ihr jetzt trotzdem dass
alle großen und wichtigen erfindungen
schon entdeckt und erfunden wurden
aber allein im jahr 2017 hat die
menschheit so viele daten erschaffen wie
in den vorherigen 5000 jahren der
menschheitsgeschichte zusammen
zu diesen daten gehören hunderte neue
planeten tausende entschlüsselten
genomen und millionen peer reviewed
wissenschafts publikationen
wir beginnen gerade erst zu verstehen
wie unsere welt funktioniert und jede
einzelne von uns kann helfen sie zu
verbessern
niemals in der geschichte der menschheit
hatten wir mehr möglichkeiten mehr
werkzeuge und mehr grundwissen und zu
forschen zu entdecken und zu erfinden
das internet verbindet heute über 3
milliarden menschen die alle
unterschiedliche dinge wissen und andere
blickpunkte auf probleme haben
ich selber nutze jetzt gerade diese
möglichkeit um die zukunft zu verändern
dadurch dass ihr mir zuhört verändere
ich den verlauf der geschichte
vielleicht inspiriere ich den einen oder
anderen von euch eine neuartige maschine
in der garage oder eine innovative
medizin in der küche zu entdecken
vielleicht kann ich auch ein paar von
uns auf die welt um uns herum aufmerksam
machen und ihr entdeckt eine neue
tierart oder ein spannendes
wetterphänomen wir alle haben die
möglichkeit die zukunft zu verändern
wir müssen nur unsere augen offenhalten
neugierig bleiben und alte strukturen
hinterfragen wie die welt von morgen
aussieht können wir heute verändern
jede idee die wir haben jeder gedanke
den wir aussprechen kann die zukunft
formen
also was ist deine vision
vielen dank an merck für die
unterstützung bei diesem video
merck ist ein wissenschafts und
technologie unternehmen und möchte uns
alle im rahmen der neugier initiative
wieder neugieriger machen um innovation
und fortschritt zu fördern
das neue projekt road to the future ist
ein kollaboratives kunst projekt bei dem
es darum geht visionen für die zukunft
zu entwerfen wie ich die zukunft von
wissenschaft und technologie sehe habe
ich auf der website des projektes
verewigt und das kannst du auch machen
was macht dich neugierig auf die zukunft
der link dazu ist in der video
beschreibung viel spaß dabei und wie
immer bleibt neugierig
[Musik]